[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein ganz tolles
adware rezept aber was noch viel toller
ist als das apple rezept ist mein
heutiger gast ist extra angereist aus
köln kommt aber gibt für dich gar nicht
so weit weg von waghäusel dennis
eigentlich ein schwarzer ja er ist der
vater sagte lies heute zu gast erlöst
als der applaus wird dann hinterher
eingehe ok wack umbau des konzerns kommt
dann hinterher affenhaus und richtig
tobender applaus
mit standing ovations
ja dass der fahrer ist sogar
ich denke die meisten vielleicht haben
ebenso wie bei mass effect ob denn du
machst ja wirklich sehr viel wut content
kochen bis zum backen no bay
packers wäre ich nicht so der focus ich
traue mich doch nicht so an da kommt das
ändern wir wirklich sind also hätte ich
könnte ich das was du kannst mutig mehr
backen ja dann kriegen wir das hin und
dann gibt es bremst der fahrer bald noch
mehr backrezepte ich freue mich ja ich
glaube dass die menschen an deinem kanal
so leben sie in also die einfachen
rezepte für jeden tag kochen wenn man
gerade lust drauf hat oder eben auch
hunger hat und da kann man bei de
vorbeischauen da geht es echt sehr sehr
viele rezept inspirationen ich muss auch
dazu sagen dass samira unsere tochter
elf jahre alt die kocht ja auch schon
ganz viel selber die bank auch viel und
sie können auch selbst ausmacht hass und
visionäre ja die kommt auch später um 17
uhr von der schule und dann musst du
leider noch hier sein natürlich ist
dies heute da die hat die schreit nicht
im kindergarten jedenfalls habe ich mir
gedacht können wir heute
braune cups packen später nur so eine
leckere creme rein erdbeeren drauf es
halt so dass perfekt für die erdbeerzeit
denke ich habe es noch nicht gemacht
also wir machen besitzer zusagen zum
ersten mal ich hab ich gedacht das wird
cool wird bestimmt ich habe max
druckbranche
sagte erdbeeren ich liebe irgend welche
allergien
wirklich mag ich gehöre zu denen die
meldung aus dem wenige tatsächlich ich
weiß nicht ihr könnt ihr mal gerne in
die kommentare schreiben ob ihr team
nach krebs jetzt oder nie seit weil ich
bin schon ich mag es sehr trocken ja
schon doch auch so jahrmärkten da gibt
es ja oft so lakritz stände aber dann
brauche ich ein ganzes diese fledermäuse
wo die in der mitte haben ihren draußen
ich mag es nicht ganz gern jedenfalls
fangen an mit den braunen cups das heißt
ihr braucht einfach nur baff in form
ohne papier förmchen den ofen haben
schon vorgeheizt dafür nehmen wir 100
gramm twitter gerade hundert computer
etwas wandel extrakt
260 gramm zucker etwas salz 200 gramm
mehl und backpulver oder verwendet das
bak mail 40 kam cacau 100 gramm
gemahlene mandeln und 100 gramm
mineralwasser das war es auch schon also
ich hab die zutaten immer da das ist so
oder vorratsschrank das ist ja ich
wollte mich auch entschuldigen weil ich
keine stimme haben
also beispiel das klingt noch mal nicht
so gut es ist nicht so dass ich bin hier
reinkommen jetzt die sprache verschlagen
noch vom wochenende aber ich wurde
ja was ist nämlich auch nicht wusste
tatsächlich habe ich hab zwar über dich
oft gelesen und ich folge dir auch schon
länger aber ich wusste nicht dass du
tatsächlich events viele organisierte
als eventmanager ich habe sport und
event das studiert
[Musik]
mal spaß können manchmal so eine zelle
caravelle in cooles event anna lacht
ja okay also zuerst erschmolzen wir die
butter und die schokolade und kann man
entweder in der mikrowelle machen oder
auf dem herd da wir machen es einfach
außen her wie willst du bist der boss
straße ok dann kannst du gerne die
butter rhein geben und einfach nur bei
niedriger stufe schmelzen an sich das
soll jetzt nicht zu heiß werden und
sobald die dann fast schon eingestellt
und sobald die gleich geschmolzen ist
mathe hatte gehen wir dann die
schokolade trocken sonst brennt die
amazon sie
hier was gelernt ja bald die mutter die
so lange warm werden und nicht zu heiß
und dann können wir die in der restwärme
so ein bisschen schmerzen
gab es schon mal was in der küche was
dir komplett misslungen ist
ja ich
versuche ich irgendwie auch sagen zu
free state und da wollte ich irgend so
ein roboter
süßkartoffel auflauf machen das hat gar
nicht funktioniert und dann habe ich
aber auch gezeigt dass wir jetzt endlich
geklappt ja leute auch mega krise
dementsprechend kann ich immer alles
klappt
wie es denn bei dir was heißt so ist ein
zwei rezepte oder gesagt das wirklich
also eigentlich gelingt mir immer alles
nix sagt es
so eine tolle kanal
natürlich nicht
ich hatte auch schon eine überschwemmung
hiernach mit acker
sind diese drei liter ag aus der torte
ausgelaufen
neulich hatten
wattenmeer ist es zuckerwatte
zuckerwatte maschine hat angefangen zu
brennen
die gesamte partie bot maschinen oder
wie ich echt prof
[Musik]
ich habe auch schon als ich oreo kekse
gebacken habe vielleicht den backofen
leicht unter brand gesetzt ist romy noch
passiert mit papier ja wieso wenn es
oben drauf kommt
ja also bei mir läuft auch nicht immer
alles klappt manchmal förderlich aber
auch aus habe sondern wie heißt die
kategorie experimente und damit schon
jetzt hat aus gut da nix mehr ist
riskant aber ich probiere es
nicht
ich kann es aber ich lasse mein bruder
meine wir haben es ja vom papa hat ja so
meine mama rumgekommen er hat die summe
noch einmal so in dem dörfchen in
hechingen papa zugehört hat es da
verliebt
webber warnte dass vom 1
ihr hättet ihr freund murat erzählt der
borat kommt ja aus balingen und der hat
nämlich gesagt dass ihr da eben aus
hechingen und das ist irgendwie alles so
einfach genau an den bali habe ich
fußball gespielt ja und doch sagt
rheinhausen hause genau das ist so
lustig ach ja der störfälle weil er
dürfte sich alles immer dörfler das
stimmt aber
warte mal geschätzt in köln deine eltern
auch okay von bruder hier sind alle
dahin gezogen und gott ich werde schon
mal die offene form denn wir brauchen
hier keine papierform stand das wird
jetzt ohne passiert
was normalerweise zwinge ich immer an
meine gäste zum karaoke singen
habe ich doppelt den schutz dann beim
nächsten mal nächste mal sehr gerne
gehört bitten möchte
da jetzt raus haben jetzt noch einmal
dran
dann können wir hier dann lasse ich dich
das jetzt machen ok wird einfach alle
zutaten rein einfach alle seien alles
rein dass ein braunes zeigt er da muss
man nicht viel beachtete hier schon auch
einfach so ein schuss so ein teelöffel
ungefähr ein extrakt
wurde ja
alles keine erkennst du zuhause freundin
alles rein ist gut da kann man nicht
viel falsch machen
meistens
wacken ist halt so schon so maßarbeit
also da muss man gut abmessen und
abwägen und sich an so grundrezepte
halten aber beim kochen kann echt alles
freestyle rein
ja
selbst gemalten wir sehen wollen mit
viel liebe auch rein
mache auch und dann war's das schon
so jetzt aber dem schneebesen
verbunden
gibt so ein rezept das sagst dass du
deine lieblings torte gibt es kuchen ja
ich glaube den leckersten kuchen den ich
gemacht habe war diese logik lotus
cheesecake der war schon recht ja
wahrscheinlich muss ich einfach du hast
du
lieblingskuchen oder blau die ihre
zwecke oder hallo das ist schon auch
favorit bei mir muss sagen ich habe
neulich sein lotus hefezopf gemacht
aber ich mag es kam er
ist cool
und zitronige sachen mag ich voll und
schokolade hast du ein level gemacht
ich habe noch keinen gemacht hätten
jahrhundert glaube
nein meint hast du echt
und dann gucken wir wer das wie gemacht
habe
challenge
damit der lemon cheesecake dieses jahr
der trend
beim zubereiten genau er ruhig noch ein
bisschen fester dass ich da gerne
verkauf sieht super aus
wird das so braun die blauen jusufovic
pro nie so richtig super sport
maxx tv
[Musik]
spots in ihrer und dann ganzen oder mit
wie kriegst du das dazwischen gibt einen
trick also eigentlich wenn du etwas
luftiges gerührt hättest wird cannabis
credo so hätte ich sagt nicht an den
rand schlagen weil du dann die luft raus
schlägt aber hier kannst du eigentlich
am rand so ein bisschen ausklopfen aber
ich habe zwei kinder bei denen es
eigentlich dass die schnecken reform weg
kam ein alter kommt ihm eine forderung
die schimpfen immer wenn ich zu viel
dann mit dem teig schlafzimmer alles aus
bis zum letzten rest nagt natürlich
einen löffel ablage und dann muss ich
den immer was übertreffen gott
kann ich immer so einen ice prozent voll
da so rein machen
[Musik]
das ruhig so hinzugehen ich dich mir
aufgefallen dass alle die bei mir hier
in der küche sind die fragen dann immer
so höflich erst habt ihr angst vor mir
okay
der sturm war nämlich auch recht brav
bei mir in der küche da ist einfach so
ganz einstimmen und
mächtig
sehr gut dann kommt es jetzt schon in
den backofen
gebacken werden wir nutzen die
zwischenzeit und werden jetzt noch für
uns der pharma und rezept zubereiten da
schaut doch einfach auf instagram optik
doch vorbei und
interessanter ist da könnt ihr das video
nämlich auch räumlich und das kommen die
zehn ofen danach ist es abkühlen und
dann geht es weiter mit der creme
[Musik]
die tagesschau heute um die
hafenarbeiter
heute in
waghäusel barkhausen die metropole statt
im metropol kam ein sehr starker bin ich
durch aber das ist wohl nicht der weiß
welche markt aus der bronx sondern bei
gefallen was genau ich muss auch sagen
zwei hans nicht aus der frauen geschafft
da hab ich wahrscheinlich nicht genug
eingefettet aber uns reichen die sowieso
was wir brauchen ist nicht ob es mir vor
geschaffen die werden zerkrümelt und
werden einfach so gegessen
wird ein glas daraus gemacht
sagen die frauen ja
wir werden jetzt eine frisch käsecreme
zu bereiten frischkäse sahne creme und
dann kommt da noch etwas rein und dann
wird das ganze echt ziemlich lecker
glaube ich hoffe ich wir haben hier 250
gramm frischkäse 50 gramm puderzucker
etwas tonka passte 250 gramm sahne und
seiner party zum start schlagen tonga
rossi casey tonkabohnen hatte ich muss
dich ich muss dich da draußen
ist ein tabu
das wie vanille so ein richtig geniales
gewehre leute das mariechen und die muss
man hat ganz fein mahlen oder mit kochen
zum beispiel und ich habe daraus sonder
tanker pasta entwickelt dann kann man
das so ganz einfach dosieren lecker und
die sind auch giftig wenn man so viele
und entwickelt oder muskat und deswegen
ist raptor da kann man nix überdosieren
sogar veganer liebe ja
genau dann darfst du gerne herr
frischkäse puderzucker und tonka hier
eingeben
dass es nicht schwer oder das rezept
philosophie so ein bisschen besser noch
so vieles viel geschmack und diese
lücken
die noch nicht erst kurz berühren
genau
durchsucht
[Musik]
ich muss immer auf meine formulierung
auf was aber ist erst rein stecken und
dann machen locken
es sind jetzt höher und danken dir
langsam die sahne dazugeben
ist das schon mal passiert dass seine
geronnen ist beim aufschlagen ja weil es
denn zu wahren
ich muss sagen jemals sein es war lustig
war angeschlagen geschlagen geschlagen
was soll ich sagen ist doch gut
besuchten ja ja das was da wieder
richtig butter kurz raus und
dann schreib schlagen
[Musik]
super ausguck perfekt
überkopf test
und da kommt es jetzt einen spritzbeutel
rein aber wenn man keinen spritzbeutel
hat geht es auch ohne man kann das auch
im löffel dann einfüllen mit doch nicht
ganz so hübsch aber trotzdem danke
ich wusste gar nicht dass sie einen
spritzbeutel halter gibt ja
arbeiten auf spritzmittel halt allein
kann tatsächlich
stimmt es gut als in diesem geiste mit
spritze ständer genannt und dann lachen
immer alle und ich muss mich mal
ausreden dann haben wir das und hier
unsere
bin ich gerade überlegen ob wir
praktisch cupcakes draus machen aber
eigentlich war meine grundidee wir
nehmen das hier so weg
so dann hören wir dass so ein bisschen
aus
ja
genauso ursprünglich wollte ich es
nämlich so eindrücken im glas so war
noch eindrücken aber dann ist so dann
ist schon so ein bisschen rum gemacht
als wir können quasi wieso kennt zum
maulwurf kuchen
ein maulwurf kuchen mäßig dass so ein
bisschen aus höhlen oder
wir lassen so umspritzen halt nur drauf
können wir wollten mal gucken wie es
aussieht
ich kann so das aushöhlen sparen ja aber
nach
so
dass rechts- oder linkshänder rechts
dann muss es am besten so dass die
rechte hand oben fragte den druck ausübt
und die linken führt und es ist ein
bisschen so
ja
ja das hat ein anderes teil
fangen in der mitte an genau und
aufrecht halten
und da und gar nicht so einen riesigen
bogen
wo ich zeige noch einmal da kannst du
noch mal
ich fange ich an und dann
ja so einen kleinen kreis das kriegst du
hinten
ja ja ja das ist
dann der
sport bild doch wie kommen wir noch mal
so
man muss man mit dem druck schon so ein
bisschen so einen leichten druck dass es
sich so nach außen
drückt aber
ja ja ja ja
oder man macht halt einfach einen
anderen style ja oder ja
es geht mir keine richtig und falsch
das ist nur nicht schön wie meinst und
schön wie sind ist er hat das ok du
machst nur die letzten damals noch mal
da kann sich nochmals 9,8 ich will sie
ja okay und dann gebe ich dir noch einen
anderen machen
es sieht so aus dass schon bei weight
watchers ich habe heimlich geübt
das problem ist die sind echt zu voll
gefüllt gewesen ich hab's ja außen nicht
eingesprüht also
machen wir warten noch eine raus kam das
schafft ich glaub an dich
ja
in den isu- sie ja das ist mir leid es
war mein fehler
jetzt und daneben war erdbeeren
und die können zum beispiel auf fächern
und dann können wir die so gefächert
drauf machen uns ein bisschen schokolade
drüber raspeln oder
wie max kruse dekorieren
[Musik]
ins schwarze
das wissen ob ich habe das jetzt hier so
weggeschnitten
ich habe übrigens ein paar fragen
gesammelt
in meiner story und ich soll mich fragen
wie man deinen namen komplett richtig
ausspricht weil ich hätte jetzt stefano
gesagt
ich weiß ja dass so aber können bad
cannstatt schwäbisch schwätza bis wir
kommen
einfach hier so
eine steinplatte da passiert nichts
das vorderste weg
direkt gestern
die app heraus da haben
vor allem kam heute morgen und sagt so
hatte elektriker ist so süß und dann
habe ich ganz weg erst mal das glas und
dialekten ist
schön guck mal wie königlich wow
könig der berge das richtig königlichen
das hat immer eine andere technik ohne
seine macht ja diese erhabene
ja ich glaube so sowie geklebt ja recht
gut aus erst die beim backen lassen
müssen ja ich will dazu aber bei so viel
rezept videos auf tag da irgendwann kann
ich nicht mehr essen gestimmt dann
kann man solche machen das habe ich weil
ich muss ein
paar sachen
dachte ich wow
auf seinem kanal du kochst ja viel
und schon viel pasta auge wer stört auch
manchmal dafür gerettet wenn du mont
pasta basta jörg weil ich krieg da schon
auch immer so weil es immer heißt nudeln
müssen kochen und also ich sag immer
meine meinung es gibt noch keinen
wirklich richtig oder falsch sondern
sogar spaß macht und schmeckt und
schmeckt richtig wenn wir das ein
italiener sagt dann stimmt es auch dann
darf ich weiterhin meine band passt da
machen ist du bist dabei also mit einem
ja
natürlich darfst los ich muss auch sagen
wir haben es damals auch auf der
speisekarte und
es war okay also ich bin damit oft wirkt
okay die sauger aus dies sieht auch
richtig gut aus meine güte die werden
immer besser her
welche weinmeister
[Musik]
die durch protzige kühlschrank
zeige ich aber einen richtigen torten
profi hier okay das ist eller und eller
ist sechs jahre alt und
sie kann das schon richtig gut ich
leider nicht mehr ganz so viel creme
übrig mein schatz aber es wird reichen
oder warte ich kenne das oben kurz ab
jetzt vollgas
es sind auch gemein mit einem halbleeren
spritzbeutel hier besteht
noch ein bisschen mehr
guck mal hier ist jetzt noch mal
geschneit den beutel hinweg da musst du
nicht so viel halten
halten oben zu
so eine richtige torten künstlerin die l
max noch erdbeeren
keine
karotten
der glitzerstadt
probieren
unseren schiefen turm von waghäusel
okay
war es echt schwierig
erwin zerstört
und
ich nehme einfach so noch eine erdbeere
weil bei mir jetzt keine abwehr drauf
das weiß ich ja
und damit er davon
es ist gut geworden
entschuldigung ich wollte nicht auf dich
selber zwar kennt aber das war von der
erdbeere das wasser
bis zufrieden
also würde
so das war unser erstes kennenlernen
tatsächlich denn wir haben uns zwar
vorher schon so ein bisschen über social
media kennengelernt aber
eigentlich so richtig kann im internet
eigentlich uns jetzt so beim kochen und
backen kennengelernt das heißt es weiter
man das erste video von uns beiden weil
sie noch mehr sehen wollt schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
und da dürft ihr euch auch gerne rezepte
wünschen und das zweite rezept was wir
gemacht haben finden wir bei dir
auf instagram und
ist überall und mir hat sehr viel spaß
gemacht ich hoffe dass ich ein bisschen
was gelernt bei mir und ich habe selten
so viel
was park in betrieb
und natürlich auch von unserer
konditormeisterin her das ist die zweite
hat es richtig drauf hier in der küche
also macht es gut bis zum nächsten mal
das rezept findet ihr wie immer in
meiner apple oder auf meinem blog
er ist immer noch nicht fertig dann
überlassen wir jetzt einfach die küche
genau du bist im geschäft
das fertig
was fehlt noch was macht dann noch drauf
jetzt haben wir aber streusel mit muffin
nicht mal mit
ok weiß mal ab
und
unglaublich lücke ist gut geworden
der sieht ja richtig hübsch
war es
super gut aus
[Musik]